a majority of Democrats they don't want
Joe they want another option Kamala
Harris go right ahead
joining us now with reaction let's give
a warm welcome to Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy
senator
we have 13 dead Americans we had John
Kirby at that Podium lying through his
teeth you know I didn't really care when
my kids you know they got involved in a
little bit of Mischief nothing like I
did
um that didn't bother me but if they
said I didn't do it when I don't I knew
they did I got really angry about that
part of it in this case you have a
president lying over and over again like
he never once talked to Hunter about his
foreign business dealings that was a lie
too but this is a Lie the cost American
lives and we now have hostages being
held in Afghanistan
President Biden's report on Afghanistan
Sean is a fable
the American people may be poorer under
President Biden but they're not stupid
uh President Biden's approval rating
ranks right up there with jock itch
among the American voters
uh and there's there's a there's
[Applause]
a reason for that uh it's the
president's in part his surrender to the
Taliban in Afghanistan now that's not
the only thing that the body
Administration has screwed up they're
never just one or two cockroaches uh
President Biden has mismanaged Congress
he's mismanaged covet he's mismanaged
the Border he's mismanaged crime he's
mismanaged the Spy balloon he's
mismanaged the economy he's mismanaged
Fentanyl and he's he's forfeited our
energy Independence but his surrender to
the Taliban in Afghanistan was
especially egregious
because it telegraphed as you pointed
out to China and Russia and North Korea
and Iran that he President Biden
intended to pursue peace through
weakness
and peace through weakness never works
now those are the facts it gives me no
joy to recite them
but um on unless you're awoker
or unless you have a necktac tattoo or
unless you have both you're both you
know that I am correct and the American
people know that I'm correct Senator you
know we know about the economy we know
about borders we know about energy
Independence all lost we know about
Afghanistan but here's what scares me
our number one geopolitical foe is China
number two is Russia they have a line
together they have aligned also with
Iran they have now aligned also with
Saudi Arabia China brokering a deal
between Iran and Saudi Arabia and now
Saudi Arabia and the syrians you see
their presence in Africa and Latin
America and what I see happening is
because Joe Biden abdicated his role as
the leader of the Free World they are
enemies that don't have great intentions
with the world are now taking full
advantage and I think this is now
developing a new Access of Evil am I
overstating the fact
no
think back why did Putin invade Ukraine
why has China been so aggressive during
the first year or so of President
Biden's term he not only surrendered to
the Taliban he removed sanctions on the
Nordstrom 2 pipeline he got rid of the
China initiative
I mean he showed he I mean it he showed
every uh intention of trying to appease
both China and Russia
and you mentioned what scares you I'll
tell you what also scares me
um President Biden has another year and
a half
to discover new and innovative ways to
suck and it is a dangerous world out
there
Senator Kennedy I I don't have a senator
because I'm stuck in the city in New
York state I I think I'm going to adopt
you as my Senator if you don't mind
appreciate you being here thank you
Senator hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else